chers amis je vous demande d' accueillir
très chaleureusement le président notre
formation politique le président des
républicains christian jacob
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci mes chers amis
merci je veux d'abord vraiment vous
remercier tout et tout
pour votre formidable mobilisation pour
les travaux d'hier pour ceux de ce matin
ceux du début d'après midi mais aussi
pour votre engagement et votre
militantisme de terrain en ayant répondu
aussi nombreux à notre appel
vous avez vous avez fait taire tous ces
oiseaux de mauvaise augure
et vous avez vu qu'ils étaient un peu
nombreux ces derniers jours donc c'était
bien d'avoir répondu aussi largement et
en étant aussi mobilisé merci encore ça
a été dit par beaucoup de mes
prédécesseurs à cette tribune
mais quel autre parti politique est
capable aujourd'hui de rassembler plus
de 1000 jeunes pendant deux jours pour
parler politique pour travailler et
parler de l'avenir de notre pays
on les met tous au défi de le faire ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui et
fondateur d'un sursaut d'une droite
moderne ouverte et résolument tourné
vers l'avenir
merci d'être venus de toute la france de
la métropole et d'outre-mer permettez
moi aussi de remercier notre équipe
dirigeante
guillaume pelletier notre premier vice
président aurélien pradié vous pouvez
tous les applaudir
annie genevard présidente du conseil
national
eric ciotti président de la commission
d'investiture je voudrais vous dire que
chaque jour ils sont à mes côtés
ils m'apportent leur soutien leurs
conseils leur aide et ses conseils me
sont vraiment très précieux c'était
l'occasion de leur dire merci
aujourd'hui avec un mot particulier vous
le comprendrez pour pour aurélien qui a
très largement contribué à la réussite
de ces deux jours il a passé sans doute
un mois d'août un peu animé là peut-être
pas passée je dirais des nuits calmes et
tranquilles mais en tout cas il a réussi
avec vous cette formidable opération
merci merci aux liens merci aussi à nos
trois présidents de groupe à françois
xavier à bruno à damien vous savez merci
pour leur présence mais bien au delà de
leur présence pour le talent qui est le
leur a animé le groupe parlementaire
c'est un job que je connais bien je sais
ce qu'il ce qu'ils demandent et
honnêtement vous les avez vu ce matin on
peut être très très très fier de nos
trois présidents de groupe
merci encore à tous les fronts merci je
n'oublie pas bien entendu mon ami
françois françois baroin président de la
mmf ne reviens pas sur ce qu'il est sur
ce qu'il représente sur
le charisme l'expérience et la
compétence qui est la sienne
merci françois d'état voire d'avoir été
avec nous et puis gérard gérard larcher
notre infatigable président du sénat
infatigable artisan de l'unité de
l'union et du rassemblement
il a su depuis déjà quelques années
redonner à la haute assemblée
une dimension qu'elle n'avait plus un
grand merci du fond du coeur gérard je
veux également remercier et saluer les
membres du bureau politique du conseil
stratégique nos députés nos sénateurs
nos députés européens nos élus
territoriaux et à ce titre mon ami
renaud muselier président de
l'association des régions des régions de
france qui avec nous depuis ce matin
alors vous le savez aussi un événement
comme celui-ci nécessite une
organisation d'ampleur et c'est aussi
l'occasion de dire merci à tous les rdj
au conseil national des jeunes à oran à
tous ceux qui ont contribué à la
réussite de cette journée de ces deux
jours et enfin pour en terminer avec le
remerciement mais c'est pas le plus
désagréable aussi il faut aussi savoir
dire merci à toute l'équipe des périodes
de permanents de la rue de vaugirard qui
ont été mobilisés tout l'été et bon
nombre d'entre eux pendant leurs congés
croyez moi ils ont été militant parmi
les militants
merci à eux alors il ya un an mes amis
dans un contexte difficile dont chacun
se souvient j'ai décidé de prendre mes
responsabilités et ne me présenter à la
présidence de notre mouvement je veux
d'ailleurs adressé un message d'amitié à
laurent wauquiez qui a pris une décision
difficile celle d'assumer seul une
défaite qui était collective il l'a fait
avec beaucoup de dignité
je me suis présentée parce que la
fidélité à mes idéaux à mes valeurs en
ma famille politique sont pour moi vous
le savez des valeurs cardinales parce
que je suis par construction par mon
parcours aussi un homme de combat et
surtout surtout parce que je crois et
j'aspire plus que jamais à l'alternance
comme beaucoup de français je n'ai en
vérité pas digéré les fractions de
l'élection présidentielle de 2017
mais les événements depuis juin 2017 et
spécialement au cours des six derniers
mois ont renforcé ce sentiment que le
président de la république n'était pas
prêt et qu'il mène une mauvaise
politique pour notre pays
les élections municipales ont été un
signal profond de la réalité d'un double
rejet le rejet des manuels macro lui
même mais le rejet du maquereau nisme on
nous annonçait l'implantation d'un
mouvement local en marche jeune moderne
dynamique
on nous annonçait la fin de l'ancien
monde eh bien on n'a pas été déçu aux
municipales la république en marche a
été balayée par tous ils ont réussi à
faire des listes et pourtant ce n'est
pas faute d'avoir essayé de brouiller
les cartes
mais leur échec a été cinglant ils ont
raté leur ancrage ce qui est finalement
pas surprenant pour un parti hors sol
nos candidats parce qu'ils étaient bons
parce qu'ils avaient de bons bilans
parce qu'ils ont su rassembler ont
obtenu des résultats remarquables
nous partions de très haut avec les
municipales de 2014
nous avons tenu nos positions avec bien
sûr quelques déceptions mais aussi de
formidables conquête
moyennant quoi les républicains
aujourd'hui si nous prenons les villes
de plus de 30 mille habitants ce sont 50
% des villes que nous détenons ses 15
millions d'habitants qui sont des vrais
commune à l'air autant que tous les
autres partis politiques
additionnez voilà on arrive le résultat
des municipales 50% des villes sont
heller
en 2020 comme en 2014
on peut dire la tête haute que les
républicains sont le parti des
territoires de la proximité de
l'efficacité locales et de la
reconnaissance du terrain alors il y a
donc ce ce paradoxe
nous n'avons pas encore capitaliser à
l'échelle nationale sur cette réalité de
terrain que l'on constate partout en
france
mais je suis convaincu que le temps de
la récolte viendra il viendra parce que
ce décalage n'est pas lié à notre
histoire notre histoire c'est celle d'un
grand parti de droite qui a donné à la
france ses institutions avec et autour
du général de gaulle qui lui a donné
nous l'avons vu il ya un instant
plusieurs grands président de la
république
si les français avaient voulu que nous
disparaissions ne serions plus là
il n'imagine pas en réalité au plus
profond d'eux-mêmes que la vie politique
française puisse se structurer sans un
grand mouvement de droite capable
d'assurer l'alternance un grand parti de
gouvernement qui puisse demain reprendre
en main le destin de notre pays
le temps de la récolte viendra est ce un
paysan qui vous le dit car nous avons en
nous cette cohérence idéologique une
ligne politique que nous venons de
réaffirmer avec un travail considérable
transpi dans un rapport d'étape que nous
avons envoyés dans toutes nos
fédérations départementales ce travail
de fond inédit dans notre famille
politique va nous permettre la tenue
d'un congrès des idées à l'automne
prochain
toutes et tous au sein de notre famille
politique nous savons nous retrouver sur
les grands sujets nous l'avons vu depuis
deux jours et sur les grandes questions
tout et tout
même si pour exister parfois les
tonalités sont différentes nous nous
retrouvons sur la liberté
nous nous retrouvons sur l'autorité nous
nous retrouvons sur le progrès voilà ce
que nous incarnons voilà notre ligne
politique et ce triple message il est
porteur d'espoir pour notre pays qui
voit bien que le en même temps et
d'abord anne immobilisme sans
perspectives
alors évidemment j'ai la lucidité de
dire qu'il nous a manqué parfois
vie d'union cette envie qui peut
déplacer des montagnes l'envi du
compagnonnage et enfin l'envi du
collectif face auquel les petits
trajectoires personnelles sont bien peu
de choses c'est le sens de l'action que
je mène avec notre équipe dirigeante
faire et refaire travailler ensemble
dans la maison commune tous ceux qui en
ont sincèrement envie j'y mets toute mon
énergie
car je suis convaincu que notre maison
commune reste un point fixe une
référence le cadre pour un vrai projet
d'avenir pour ceux qui s'y sentent bien
et aussi pour ceux qui est ce qu'ils
sont bien sûr toujours rester mais aussi
pour ceux qui à un moment ont pu douter
mais en réalité ont bien vu avec ces
élections municipales que c'est aux
républicains et à la qualité de leurs
élus que les français ont fait confiance
avec ce travail collectif nous avons
donné une belle image de ce que nous
sommes des militants ouvert à l'ecoute
fiers de leur valeur capable aussi de
faire bouger les choses se remettre en
question de proposer d'être en
initiative
et c'est parce que nous faisons ce
travail de fond sur nous mêmes que nous
retrouverons le coeur des français et
que nous serons fidèle à la vocation
historique qui est celle d'un grand pays
parti gaulliste qui consiste à
rassembler les français à les mobiliser
à les entraîner dans leur diversité vers
un projet ambitieux pour la france n'en
doutons pas un instant tout viendra du
travail que nous avons initiées pour
parler aux français parlé aux français
c'est évidemment parler à tous les
français de tous les sujets parler aux
français c'est parler à nos électeurs
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est aussi parler à
ceux d'hier qui peuvent redevenir ceux
de demain
nous ne devons pas nous résoudre à ce
que les français sincèrement de droite
soient condamnés à choisir entre la
république en marche et le rassemblement
national
et oui il en reste de moins en moins
mais suffisamment pour que les
commentateurs continuent à phosphorer
sur la plus grande fête news et dernière
année qui était dénoncé par gérard y un
instant monsieur macron serait de droite
alors oui parce que parce que l'homme
est ainsi fait il peut arriver un jour
qu'un chef de gouvernement pour cocher
une case dans un cv renvoi par la poste
la carte des républicains la veille de
sa nomination à matignon
ça peut arriver ça en dit long sur la
colonne vertébrale de l'intéressé mais
sans doute avait-il était inspiré par
l'opportunisme de son prédécesseur mais
les français ont bien compris qu'en
réalité on cherchait alors servir la
même limonade une seconde fois et que
tout cela est en réalité un signifiant
complètement insignifiant au regard du
jugement qu'ils sont en droit de porter
sur monsieur macron après trois ans et
demi d'exercice du pouvoir
le tableau est désormais précis et
jaurès d'une manière d'ailleurs assez
stupéfait de ce qui est pardonné ou
semble être pardonné à monsieur macron
des propos honteux souvenez-vous
certains de nos concitoyens seraient des
illettrés d'autres des alcooliques
d'hôtes serait rien on peut également à
propos du pognon de dingue que coûte
notre sécurité sociale et que dire sur
la protection d'un individu sulfureux
monsieur benalla dont deux ans après
laffaire on ne sait toujours pas ce qui
a justifié la proximité et la connivence
avec le président de la république mais
sans
c'est pour la forme et puis il ya le
fond le fond c'est ce maquereau nisme
qui a été vendue comme le grand sursaut
de la réforme de la france on allait
voir ce que l'on allait voir avec ce
jeune et fringant président eh bien on a
vu
et comme aurait dit jacques chirac eh
bien ça fait chic des réformes mal
comprise mal préparés engendré ont
engendré le blocage du pays à deux
reprises avec les gilets jaunes d'abord
puis avec la contestation de la réforme
des retraites qui a ré avec l'arrivée de
monsieur castex a bénéficié d'un
enterrement de première classe
il est temps il est grand temps que nous
tordons le cou avesque à ce canard le
président de la république mènerait une
politique de droite les faits et les
chiffres sont accablants
il montre une chose simple le maquereau
nice est en réalité une excroissance du
hollandisme emmanuel macron a travaillé
avec françois hollande
il a inspiré la politique économique
socialiste
il a été ministre de l'économie il a
fait voter des lois catastrophique pour
la république
il a voulu déréglementé des des
professions qui fonctionnait bien
il s'est attaqué aux commerces de
centre-ville en étant le chantre de la
grande distribution
il a voulu tuer le rail en créant les
bus macron et maintenant il nous
explique qu'il faut laisser une grande
place aux rails
comprenne qui pourra mais tout cela
montre une chose c'est qu'il ne comprend
pas les français
il ne saisit pas le pays c'est triste
pour la france car beaucoup de temps a
été perdu mais j'ai envie de dire ce
n'est même pas une occasion perdue car
le maquereau nisme portait en lui dès
2017 la certitude de l'immobilisme
tout le monde voit bien qu'à 18 mois de
la fin de son quinquennat
plus rien ne bougera souvenez vous de ce
que nicolas sarkozy avait été capable de
faire dans les premières années de son
mandat
la loi tepa la carte judiciaire les
peines planchers chère rachida
l'autonomie des universités la grande
réforme grande réforme des retraites et
je pourrais continuer ainsi à on est
bien loin de tout cela il ya un instant
je vous parlais de chiffres pas des
chiffres avant la crise du coc vide pas
les chiffres pardon d'après la crise du
copine mais ceux d'avant c'est cela qui
sont intéressants alors le pouvoir va
tenter de nous expliquer que son élan
réformateur a été coupé par cette crise
sans précédent c'est vrai qu'elle est
sans précédent cette crise mais ce qui
est sans précédent aussi c'est les
conditions dont le new lac dans
lesquelles nous l'avons abordé la
situation dans laquelle nous étions en
mars dernier la dépense publique a
augmenté entre 2017 et 2019 plus
rapidement qu'elle avait augmenté au
début des années hollande ça c'est une
réalité les prélèvements obligatoires
ont augmenté se sont concentrés sur les
classes moyennes sur les familles sur
les retraités le déficit
il était l'un des pires de la zone euro
la dette et la dépasser les 100% du
produit intérieur brut
sans parler du déficit de la balance
commerciale si aujourd'hui notre pays
est en réalité est incapable de bâtir un
plan de relance digne de ce nom sur ses
propres forces
c'est que la situation de départ était
catastrophique
le coc vide mes amis ne doit pas être le
prétexte pour cacher mentir ou travestir
la réalité
emmanuel macron n'a pas réformé il a
affaibli la structure budgétaire
économique et social de notre pays
voilà la réalité de sa marque de
fabrique les français qui commencent à
s'inquiéter sérieusement de voir tous
ces milliards qui pleuvent ressentent
bien que la situation est très
préoccupante
dans ce contexte notre responsabilité de
proposer un discours clair cohérent
construit sur le respect des valeurs et
des idées qui ont toujours été les
nôtres
l'autorité de l'état et de l'ordre
républicain
la défense de la laïcité et la lutte
contre le com
ariste le travail le mérite la liberté
d'entreprendre le progrès la sortie
d'une économie et d'une société sur
fiscalisés et sur administrer la défense
d'une politique familiale
la priorité de la solidarité sur
l'assistanat et enfin l'égalité la
liberté entre les territoires
sur ces grandes questions il y a urgence
à répondre aux interrogations et aux
angoisses des français qui voit notre
pays
à bien des égards se déliter et qui ne
voient pas le chemin pour leurs propres
enfants
c'est le travail que nous avons engagées
en début d'année et sur lequel nous
allons continuer à travailler cet
automne la désagrégation de l'autorité
de l'état le pouvoir en place avec un
ministre de l'intérieur en surchauffe
verbal permanente mais en réalité
incapable d'agir qui se résigne à faire
des commentaires sur son compte twitter
a commenté les violences l'ultra
violence partout sur le territoire
mais dans quel pays sommes nous un pays
on peut se faire ligotée et dévalisé
chez soi un pays où un chauffeur de bus
peut être sauvagement assassiné un pays
où des bandes issues de communautés
étrangères peuvent mettre à sac une
ville un pays où des pseudo supporters
de foot peuvent saccagé des commerces à
deux pas de l'elysée un pays ou une
infirmière une infirmière peut être
tabassés par ce qu'elle demande le port
du masque un pays où des élus locaux des
marchandages et physique face à de
petits caïds
jusqu'où ira-t-on dans l'inaction la
colère monte partout en france les
français ont passé ce stade où il
souhaitait que l'on empêche les
délinquants de dormir ce qu'ils veulent
c'est qu'il soit interpellé jugés
condamnés et emprisonnés et qu'il purge
totalité de leur peine
pour cela il y a un impératif réaffirmer
notre confiance absolue à nos policiers
et nos gendarmes instiller le doute en
permanence sur les violences policières
est inadmissible et insupportable
nos policiers et nos gendarmes font un
travail de gardiens de l'ordre
républicain dans des conditions très
difficiles
et lorsqu'ils commettent une faute
légitimement ils sont sanctionnés
moi je vous le dis je serai toujours par
principe et par conviction profonde
à leurs côtés en défenseur de l'autorité
car si l'autorité politique lâche la
police républicaine elle prend le risque
que la situation devienne totalement
incontrôlable
un sursaut rapide et puissant s'impose
avec une absolue nécessité
la fin du sous-équipement des forces de
l'ordre nous devons aussi nous donner
les moyens d'inverser la tendance sur le
plan judiciaire il faut mettre fin au
désarmement pénale des années tout
virant cela signifie des peines
planchers automatique pour lutter contre
la récidive et contre toute agression
envers les dépositaires de l'ordre
public
ça veut dire la suppression des
réductions automatiques de peine ça veut
dire l'abaissement de la majorité pénale
à 16 ans et puis parce que la place d'un
délinquant c'est la prison un vrai plan
prisons
je note d'ailleurs que dans cette
attente des places sont disponibles
puisque treize mille prisonniers ont été
libérés pendant le coït qui pour qui
c'était une véritable bénédiction
le défi de l'autorité de l'état en
appelle un autre auquel il a intimement
liées le défi de l'amour de la nation et
de la république
la france a su intégrer des générations
d'hommes et de femmes qui ont choisi
reconnaissant de vivre l'aventuré
nationale
aujourd'hui le moteur de l'intégration
il n'est plus en panne
ils marchent à reculons nous avons des
questions urgentes à nous poser et des
décisions à prendre sur notre politique
migratoire sur les procédures
d'acquisition de la nationalité
française
sur les conditions du regroupement
familial sur l'avenir des étrangers
entrés illégalement sur notre territoire
le temps est venu de mettre en place des
quotas par pays par secteur d'activité
des quotas indexés sur notre véritable
capacité à intégrer et à accueillir
cette décision elle a un corollaire en
finir avec un modèle social trop
généreux que nous n'avons plus les
moyens de financer l'accès aux
allocations doit être soumis à une durée
significative de cotisations sociales et
donc de présence sur le territoire
national
ce que nous avions fait en 2011 et que
la gauche a supprimé que monsieur macro
n'a jamais rétabli les dix ans de
présence pour bénéficier d'un minimum du
minimum vieillesse ce principe de
conditionnalité doit être élargie à
d'autres allocations
la mg doit être supprimé et doit être
remplacé par une aide d'urgence
le budget de la m aujourd'hui a été
multiplié par deux en dix ans est devenu
en réalité un puits sans fond et sans
contrôle
que dire aussi des reconduites à la
frontière des illégaux étaient déboutées
du droit d'asile
une goutte d'eau doublé disons le d'une
lâcheté car pour manquer masqué par dans
notre capacité et notre manque de
volonté on régularise à bas bruit les
illégaux ne nous trompons pas c'est le
pacte républicain et nationale qui est
en jeu sur ce sujet de renoncement en
renoncement ont créé les conditions
d'une communautarisation du pays au
point que certains n'osent même plus
évoquer le sujet et préfère l'esquivé en
baissant les yeux partout sur le
territoire se développent des atteintes
à notre mode de vie
oui certains baissent les yeux devant
des réalités au coeur de certaines
villes et certains quartiers des femmes
sont interdites de cité à certaines
heures
des fonctionnaires ont le plus grand mal
à faire respecter le b à ba de la
laïcité et sous couvert d'actions
sociales ou culturelles des subventions
publiques servent à financer des
associations ou des groupes qui
défendent un autre modèle de
civilisation que le nôtre pourquoi rien
ne bouge
rien ne bouge parce que monsieur macron
pense qu'il faut plutôt s'attaquer à la
radicalisation de la laïcité plutôt qu'à
la radicalisation de l'islam parce
qu'ils pensent que le voile dans les
passes de l'espace public ça n'est pas
son affaire la commission type stasi que
j'avais demandée pour travailler faire
travailler sur des propositions
concrètes sur la laïcité a été balayée
d'un revers de main ils ne feront rien
l'interdiction du voile à l'école
l'interdiction de la burqa c'est nous
c'est la droite est de retour au pouvoir
loin de tout angélisme candeur ou
naïveté
nous devrons prendre des mesures fortes
que les français attendent ça veut dire
l'expulsion des étrangers en lien avec
les mouvances islamistes
ça veut dire la fermeture des mosquées
salafistes le respect des valeurs de la
laïcité dans tous les services et dans
tous les espaces publics avec le souci
permanent bien évidemment de ne jamais
stigmatiser nos compatriotes musulmans
mais en imposant l'extrême fermeté qui
exige le respect du pacte républicain la
république doit assurer à tous la
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire
mais ou qu'une croyance ne doit pouvoir
s'imposer aux lois de la république
rien par on nous aussi du travail de la
valeur travail depuis des années et plus
encore depuis quelques mois dans un pays
qui a vécu comme une véritable
humiliation humiliation la pénurie de
masques
la pénurie de respirateurs on parle de
relocalisation et on a raison de parler
de relocalisation mais soyons sérieux la
france ne redeviendra jamais une grande
puissance industrielle
si personne ne pose sérieusement le
sujet du temps de travail du coût du
travail et du niveau des revenus de
l'assistanat
si ces trois sujets ne sont pas posées
on n'y arrivera pas la france ne sera
pas rompre avec le chômage des jeunes
avec cette tragédie des dizaines de
milliers de jeunes qui sortent chaque
année inemployables d'un système
scolaire qui tourne à vide
si elle n'est pas capable de faire la
révolution de la formation initiale
cette révolution c'est celle de
l'enseignement technique c'est celle de
l'apprentissage françois l'a évoqué tout
à l'heure c'est l'une des clés pour
renouer avec l'en but nos missions de
production et le plein emploi pour la
jeunesse de france
les républicains doivent être ce grand
parti qui revendique le travail qui
revendique le progrès et l'innovation
qui revendique une vraie relance dans la
durée pour les générations de demain qui
doit se mobiliser sur la recherche
médicale sur la recherche variétale en
agriculture sur l'intelligence
artificielle sur la priorité de
l'industrie de toute l'industrie y
compris le nucléaire qui est une chance
pour la france assume et l'innovation
ce n'est évidemment pas jouer les
apprentis sorciers et empêcher le
politique de prendre ses responsabilités
lorsque c'est nécessaire je les fait en
son temps en faisant voter la loi
d'interdiction d'exploration
d'exploitation des huiles et des gaz de
schiste oui nous sommes légitimes à
parler d'environnement et d'écologie
oui nous assumons notre héritage celui
du principe de précaution en
l'enrichissant d'un principe
d'innovation oui posons un discours
clair sur l'écologie
en définissant les contours d'un grand
pacte national de production agricole
alimentaire et énergétique
notre agriculture et notre industrie
agroalimentaire ont la capacité et les
moyens de le faire encore faut-il les
soutenir en fixant quelques lignes
rouges en étant cohérent en construisant
une barrière écologique aux frontières
de l'union européenne
une vraie barrière écologique
alimentaire et sanitaire au niveau
européen avec une politique en matière
de commerce et de concurrence qui doit
être totalement revu pour favoriser nos
exports nos exportations et protéger nos
entreprises européennes l'europe et la
france ne peuvent pas être les
déversoirs de pays faute de produits
fabriqués dans des pays qui ne
respectent pas les normes que nous
imposons à nos industriels et que nous
imposons à nos paysans un moyen et long
terme ce new deal agricole
agroalimentaire et industriel c'est plus
de richesses et plus de perspective
c'est aussi pour des milliers de
français qui vivent heureux en milieu
rural et périurbain une meilleure
qualité de vie sur des territoires
dynamiques et le respect d'un héritage
français d' équilibre où les territoires
les plus éloignées des grandes
métropoles n'ont pas vocation à devenir
les trous noirs du développement
économique
en un mot c'est le respect de la
géographie et de l'histoire de france
qui se joue sur ce sujet
pour renouer avec ce grand pat de
travail de croissance de progrès social
nous avons au moment où les déficits et
la dette sont hors de contrôle des
questions à nous poser collectivement
est ce raisonnable que la dépense
publique pèse plus de 56 % de notre
produit intérieur brut
ou plutôt la bonne question est ce
tenable
l'allemagne avec 44 % est elle un pays
moins bien à nice l'administré où l'on
vit en moins bonne santé ou les services
publics hospitaliers n'ont pas fait leur
preuve au moment et face à la pandémie
évidemment que non visons avant les 44%
50 % de dépenses publiques
ce serait 120 milliards de baisses de
dépenses publiques et 120 milliards
d'impôts en moins pour donner de l'élan
de l'oxygène et des forces vives au pays
aux pme aux artisans commerçants aux
agriculteurs ce débat il faut le
déconnecter de celui de la relance post
co vide et de l'aide aux secteurs les
plus durement touchés la puissance
publique doit intervenir mais sans
perdre de vue le moyen et le long terme
dans cette perspective les milliards ne
pourrons pas continuer à pleuvoir
advitam eternam
si nous ne mettons jamais sinon nous ne
mettrons jamais fin au cercle vicieux de
la paupérisation de la france et des
générations qui viennent ce sera nous ce
sera vous la jeune génération de relever
ce défi avec le souci chevillée au corps
de ne pas casser ce qui marche dans le
modèle social français
un modèle que notre famille politique a
contribué à bâtir et à réformer
à chaque fois que c'était nécessaire moi
je suis fier fier d'être d'une famille
politique qui a fait voter 2 grande loi
sur le handicap
celle de 75 et celle de 2005 fier d'être
d'une famille politique qui a tant fait
pour le droit des femmes
liv et j'ai avec simone veil et jacques
chirac c'est nous
et personne d'autre fier d'être dans une
famille politique qui a toujours depuis
1945 défendu la politique familiale que
françois hollande puis emmanuel macron
ont détricoté la fin de l'universalité
des allocations familiales comme la
baisse du quotient familial ont donné un
terrible signal
le signal que la solidarité nationale
vaut pour les uns mais ne vaut pas pour
les autres
fier enfin d'être issu d'une famille
politique qui à trois reprises a su
réformer les retraites et garantir notre
système par répartition en la matière il
y a ceux qui agissent et puis ceux qui
continuent à part les trois ans pour
échouer sur la réforme des retraites
nous sommes les seuls à avoir des
positions crédible il faudra travailler
plus longtemps pour éviter une hausse
des cotisations et une baisse des
pensions
il faudra avec force défendent les
droits familiaux et les droits conjugaux
le système d par des majorations et les
reversions pour les veuves
ce sera manifestement à nous d'y revenir
il ne fait aucun doute que sur cette
réforme
monsieur macron à calais en rase
campagne comme sur le reste d'ailleurs
vous le voyez mes chers amis rebâtir
donner à nouveau aux français à
l'échelle nationale l' envie de nous
écouter
l' envie de nous respecter de nous
suivre il faut travailler notre projet
avec conviction avec humilité avec sang
froid
c'est ce travail qui est en cours et
c'est autour de ce travail que nous
devons rester mobilisés
un travail qui s'appuie sur un socle de
valeurs la liberté l'autorité le progrès
est sur un héritage profond dans
l'histoire de notre pays
du sang froid il en faudra aussi gérard
l'a dit pour ne pas brûler les étapes
n'oublions pas qu'avant l'élection
présidentielle nous avons de grandes et
vous sur les territoires nous avons les
sénatoriales
nous avons les départementales
et les régionales toutes ces élections
sont essentielles sur le chemin de la
reconquête
alors faut-il accélérer le processus de
choix de notre candidat à l'élection
présidentielle les élections
présidentielles auront lieu dans 20 mois
vous l'avez compris pour ma part je
pense que l'heure est plus à travailler
sur ce qui nous rassemble que sur ce qui
nous divise
vous connaissez le contenu de nos
statuts sur ce sujet il puise ses
racines dans dans un mimétisme et cette
idée que les socialistes ont inventé
pour engendrer françois hollande
puis benoît hamon nous les avons copiés
nous avons organisé des primaires de la
droite et du centre
l'organisation était magnifique a été
remarquable remarquable à tel point que
même les socialistes ont participé
alors vous me connaissez je suis très
détendu sur ce sujet parce que j'ai
toujours été l'un des rares maîtres de
gros doutes et en toute franchise à ce
stade mais doutent n'ont vraiment pas
disparu la vérité est la nature de
l'élection présidentielle c'est qu'un
candidat s'impose naturellement
c'est le sens profond de cette élection
et de nos institutions
nous le savons la france va être
confronté à une rentrée sociale
économique et sanitaire très difficile
qui peut dire comment va se passer
l'automne
soyons prudents sur cela et ce loin
soyons attentifs aux réelles attentes de
nos compatriotes
nous avons par ailleurs des élections
territoriales au printemps dans ces
conditions après les élections
territoriales et avant l'été si personne
ne s'est imposé
je proposerai au bureau politique un
processus le départage sur lequel nous
aurons travaillé collectivement parce
que ça ne peut être que le fruit d'un
travail collectif et je le proposerai
aux militants parce que c'est à eux
qu'il revient de décider
c'est dans nos statuts cela doit figurer
c'est donc à eux seuls à nous tous que
la question sera posée mais d'ici là
sans relâche et dans un esprit collectif
au delà des ambitions personnelles qui
sont légitimes vous savez quand on fait
de la politique il faut avoir de
l'ambition et elles sont légitimes mais
aujourd'hui le temps est au travail
collectif
nous allons travailler sur ce projet
gagner les élections du printemps et
après nous serons sur une autre étape
vous aurez alors vous les jeunes
républicains un rôle majeur à jouer pour
faire gagner nos idées pour préparer
l'alternance pour convaincre pour
affirmer nos valeurs moi qui ai commencé
à militer à 17 ans dans une grande
organisation de jeunesse remarquablement
structuré
je veux que notre rendez vous
d'aujourd'hui soit
soit le lancement d'un grand mouvement
de jeunesse au sein de notre famille
politique dans un cadre statutaire qu'il
conviendra de définir les jeunes de
notre famille politique devront pouvoir
bénéficier d'un budget d'une gouvernance
et d'actions autonomes partout dans les
lycées dans les centres d'apprentissage
dans les universités mais aussi dans le
monde du travail les jeunes républicains
doivent être identifiés et reconnus
vous connaissez mon attachement au monde
agricole
et bien sachez dans ce week-end dans ce
milieu professionnel que je connais bien
et qui a connu des évolutions des
bouleversements comme aucun autre
mais qui a toujours su rebondir et
s'adapter aucune mesure structurante que
ce soit en matière de formation de suivi
de gestion de suivi technique de statut
d'entreprise de financement de
solidarité n'a été imaginé ou initiés
ailleurs que dans la structure jeune
nous avons aujourd'hui besoin dans notre
famille politique d'un mouvement de
jeunesse puissant implantés sur tout le
territoire dans les territoires ruraux
comme dans les territoires urbains dans
les villages comme dans les villes
je demande donc à notre secrétaire
général à aurélien pradié à pierre henri
dumont et au bureau national des jeunes
de préparer cet automne le cadre d'une
nouvelle organisation qui puisse faire
qu'au printemps les républicains rime
avec jeunesse
si nous abordons l'été prochain avec la
formidable victoire qui était la nôtre
aux municipales à laquelle nous allons
ajouter des sénatoriales réussi cher
gérard bruneau et puis auxquels nous
ajouterons j'en suis convaincu des
départementales et des régionales
victorieuse et puis également un
mouvement de jeunesse structuré et enfin
un projet politique qui réponde aux
attentes de nos concitoyens et qui
traduisent de réelles perspectives une
vraie vision pour notre pays
alors alors nous aurons toutes les armes
pour nous rassembler derrière celui ou
celle qui nous fera gagner en 2022
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]